ce qui ne te tue pas te rend plus
fort ben je crois que ça ça la phrase
veut dire ce qu'elle veut dire quoi
c'est une légende du rugby français
voici l'histoire de Christophe Dominici
ancien ailiier du 15 de France disparu
dans des circonstances
tragiques tous les ballons en l'air
c'est qui les gag tout le monde se dit
mais c'est c'est un ovni ce mec c'est
c'est fabuleux quoi on a appris
aujourd'hui la mort de Christophe
Dominici l'un des rugbyman français les
plus emblématiques de ces 30 dernières
années nous pensons très fort à famille
nous allons tâcher de lui rendre hommage
une légende du 15 de France si jeune
Christophe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Dominici cette semaine dans la grande
Histoire j'avais envie de vous parler
d'un joueur qui a marqué le rugby
français un joueur fantasque sur et en
dehors du terrain Christophe
dominicii il a fait rêver des millions
de Français comme moi en 99 même si
j'étais pas très grand à l'époque c'est
aussi l'un des premiers sportifs en
France à C re confié publiquement sur
son malêtre et sur sa dépression la vie
peut basculer très vite d'un côté comme
de l'autre ça a été ma carrière et pour
raconter son histoire j'ai rencontré
Dominique bonau la journaliste avec qui
il a écrit son autobiographie en
2007 la première anecdote rugby qui
m'est raconé c'était quand il a joué à
Toulon deux ou trois mecs qui disaient
spectateur qui disaient mais où il est
Dominici mais où il est on le voit pas
mais où il est alors l'autre il disait
bah je sais pas il est pas là ah mais si
regarde il est tout petit là le nain
derrière le ballon il est là en fait à
la fin du match il est parti en courant
il est allé les rattraper pour essayer
de leur casser la gueule en disant je
suis petit mais je vais quand même vous
casser la
[Musique]
gueule nous sommes le 31 octobre 1999 à
Londres dans l'enceinte mythique de
twikenam l'équipe de France affronte la
Nouvelle-Zélande de johnalomu qui domine
la scène mondiale depuis 4 ans
les Français sont totalement
imprévisibles s'ils sont dans un mauvais
jour c'est clair il jou mal mais dans un
bon
jourans surprise la France est dominé
Joh Mar de ESS on pens que les BL gagné
Finand il est
r
tranquille bienos pas trop
[Musique]
soucies P des couleurs Christophe
Dominici sonne la révolte tricolore en
inscrivant un essai d'antologie le
rebond lui est favorable il là et il
mistifie tout le monde tout le monde se
dit mais c'est c'est un OV ce mec c'est
c'est fabuleux quoi toute ma vie je le
repasser la France arrache la victoire
en inscrivant 33 points d'affilé en
moins d'une demi-heure une performance
qui reste à ce jour l'un des plus grands
exploits de l'histoire du rugby
[Musique]
Français
le jeune Christophe grandit à solpond
dans le Var avec ses parents et Pascal
sa grande sœur qui a 10 ans de plus que
lui mes parents travaill énormément
c'est ma sœur qui m'a élevé et qui
m'amené à l'école qui qui montra un
petit peu comment la vie fonctionne
Christophe n'a que 14 ans lorsque sa
grande sœur meurt dans un accident de
voiture il est resté enfermé 3 mois dans
sa maison il a été horriblement blessé
il s'est refermé sur lui-même c'est
comme s'il était vraiment devenu
rien du tout pour lui cet âge là je me
suis énormément culpabilisé pourquoi
elle et pas moi beaucoup de colère j'en
voulait à la vie tout simplement j'en
voulais vous auriez pu mourir de chagrin
à ce moment-là oh je pense qu'on peut
mourir de plein de choses on peut
également mourir de chagrin il a fallu
que je réagisse et je suis parti vers
l'excès voilà il faisait que des
conneries et et dans la bagarre il
exprimait sa colère il exprimait son
courage il
exprimait
l'envie d'en découdre et de prendre des
coups et en donner parce que c'était
c'était une rage contre le destin il a
fallu que je me reconstruise que je que
j'accepte du moins ce décès que j'avais
énormément de mal à vivre et voilà le
rugby surtout le rugby je pense que les
rencontres à travers le rugby le sport
m'a permis de de franchir ces
[Musique]
obstacle ici commence le rugby sur le
tard à 17 ans après avoir joué au
football comme son père qui était
gardien de but au foot lors d'un match
il s'était retrouvé tout seul enfin il
s'était retrouvé dans une bagarre et
tous les autres étaient partis et il a
dit mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
sport où les gens ne restent pas pour la
bagarre générale ça va pas du tout donc
je vais au rugby 1,72 pour 80 kg
Christophe Dominici compense son
physique atypique pour un rugbyman par
des jambes de feu et une rage de vaincre
hors du commun ses fulgurances le
conduisent vers le poste délier
lorsqu'il arrive au Racing Club de
toulom je me souviens
d'une d'une question que j'ai posé à ma
mère il y a très longtemps j'avais dit M
j'arriverai pas je suis trop
petit elle m'avait dit que j'y arriverai
que c'est pas compliqué il faut avoir
envie et il faut être
déterminé faut avoir faim voilà faut
avoir entre guillemets plus
faim que l'adversaire
Christophe Dominici est recruté par le
Stade Français le club parisien qui
vient d'être promu en Top 14 affiche de
grandes ambitions dans un sport en
pleine professionnalisation Dominici
devient champion avec le Stade Français
dès la première année il se lit d'amitié
avec le président du club max guadzini
il s'adorait vraiment mais chrait bien
alors maxisini disait devant les autres
ah mais Christophe c'est mon joueur
préféré c'était un peu vrai et en même
temps c'était pour un peu mettre un
petit peu de des petits coups de jus aux
autres star de l'équipe de France
Christophe Dominici devient le visage du
rugby aux yeux du grand public et un
exemple pour les plus jeunes il explose
tout il devient le joueur le plus le
plus connu puis il répond à toutes les
sollicitations il est ravi il adore ça
il adore rencontrer des gens il adore
parler il
adore que sentir que chez des gamins il
y avait des des passions qui naissaient
comme ça il y a beaucoup d'enfants qui
veulent se mettre au rugby maintenant
donc on a on a essayé de promouvoir le
rugby on va essayer de le faire si il
faut se déplacer pour aller dans des
écoles de rugby pour pour se montrer ben
le
fera avec le calendrier dieu du stade
qui met en scène les rugbyman du Stade
Français il joue les sex symboles il
était dans son élément parce qu'il
séduit il charme et tout ça il aimait
bien ça il monte il monte il monte en en
en puissance parce qu'il est archi connu
archi starfié et à force ben ça ça a
[Musique]
explosé quelques mois après sa rupture
avec sa première femme Christophe
Dominici plonge dans une dépression
sévère il est hospitalisé après 24 jours
d'insomn le mot c'est qui qui qui
choisit c'est j'ai failli basculer il
était obsédé par l'idée de la mort euh
il avait vraiment vraiment peur d'être
abandonné euh et d'être et de mourir
j'étais obligé de me recadrer de de r
donner un sens et un but à à ce que je
faisais
[Musique]
quoi cette année-là Christophe Dominici
dispute à 34 ans sa 3e Coupe du monde en
quart de finale le 15 de France crée une
nouvelle fois l'exploit face au All
Blacks j'ai la chance et le privilège
de de le voir souvent ce AK et celui-là
fait partic en 99 des grands moments de
sport parce que c'était il y avait une
énergie une inensité incroyable la
France s'incline face à l'Angleterre en
demi-finale Christophe Dominici voit son
rêve de devenir champion du monde
s'envoler il met un terme à sa carrière
quelques mois plus
[Musique]
tard jeune retraité Dominici refait sa
vie avec Loretta sa nouvelle femme
rencontrée un an plus tôt ensemble ils
auront deux filles Kara et Mia après une
brève expérience d'entraîneur au Stade
Français il devient consultant et
entrepreneur il Acquier notamment un
vignoble dans la région de béer quand
une terre forte de rugby et puis voilà
c'est les rencontres qui font qu'on
arrive dans des pays dans des endroits
avec des des situation des amitiés qui
se
[Musique]
créent Christophe Dominici souhaite
racheté le club de rugby de Bézier mais
pour monter ce projet il s'associe avec
un homme d'affaires franco-tunisien à la
crédibilité financière douteuse il a cru
vraiment qu'il allait pouvoir faire
quelque chose de fabuleux et il est
tombé sur un escroc qui lui avait promis
de l'argent autant qu'il en voudrait
pour faire l'équipe qu'il voulait
l'ambiance qu'il voulait parce qu'il
était visionnaire le projet de rachat
est finalement rejeté par le gendarme
financier de la Ligue de rugby furieux
Christophe Dominici réunit 300 personnes
devant le stade de Bézier une espèce de
confiance en Lui genre je peux pas
échouer je peux pas échouer moi moi
Christophe Dominici échoué non mais ça
va pas je mets en cause la validité de
la den ACG du rugby
[Applaudissements]
français et de cette institution il
était outré d'avoir été trompé comme il
l'a été il a engagé son nom il bascule
mais pour de vrai et probablement pour
les mêmes raisons c'est-à-dire elle a
peur la peur de la mort la
peur de l'abandon suite à l'échec du
racha Dominici replonge dans la
dépression il passe plusieurs jours dans
une clinique puis dans une maison de
repos on a pris cet après-midi la mort
de Christophe Dominici l'un des rugbyman
français les plus emblématiques de ces
30 dernières années Christophe Dominici
a été retrouvé mort dans ce parc des
hautes scènes après une chute de
plusieurs mètres une enquête pour
déterminer les circonstance du décès a
été ouverte par le parquet de Nère ce
soir les hommages se multiplient et le
rugby français pleure un ami un père de
deux enfants Christophe Dominici avait
48 ans on a perdu et j'ai perdu
personnellement un
ami voir un frère nous allons tâcher de
lui rendre
hommage j'ai l'impression qu'il n'est
pas mort alors qu'on me dirait il s'est
suicidé il s'est jeté du truc on l'a vu
voilà ou il a glissé ou où il lui a pris
une une hallucination voilà quoi qu'on
me dise si je préfère ne pas savoir
parce que comme ça il y a pas il y a pas
de fin à l'histoire en fait il y a pas
de
fin merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à me dire ce que vous en avez pensé
en commentaire et ce que vous aimeriez
que je tra dans les prochains épisodes
et si vous voulez regarder d'autres
vidéos de la série vous avez le lien de
la playlist dans la description à la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
grande histoire